thank you
um
so uh what I'm going to do normally I
have slides and
um and I write jokes and I try to make
whatever the talk that whatever sort of
engineering talk as entertaining as
possible but what I thought I would do
instead
um let's try something different and do
a little bit more of improvisation the
thing is I it would be I could talk
about something that I'm really
interested in and that may just bore you
all to death
um and continuous delivery is such a
large topic that
um and I have so much energy around it I
could absolutely there's no doubt in my
mind to talk for six hours
and that would suck for all of you would
be awesome for me
um uh arguably you're saving uh both my
wife and my co-workers from going
through that but by giving me an
opportunity to talk uh here um but what
I thought I'd do is get a whiteboard
because I like to draw and um maybe just
get it together like not entirely
structure this but uh maybe get some uh
a skeleton uh sort of structure and then
see how it goes from there I don't
exactly I know what words I want to
write down on the Whiteboard
um but I don't know what we should do
after that
so we're going to make it out
um
let's see four colors this will work
four orders
um
all right
so I got these four words up here
anticipation monitoring response and
learning
um
so what I want what I want everybody to
do is
um
make like a venture capitalist and
interrupt me at any moment
um raise your hands uh I don't think we
should do this uh talk about these
topics and then not have people uh like
wait until the end of
Mr John what's your you know I've got a
question about this thing that you've
had 45 minutes ago
um I I think that no matter what we no
matter how we describe continuous
delivery continuous deployment
continuous integration no matter what we
how we describe it
um uh these these bits are in play
for most of it who doesn't work uh on a
uh a property on the internet
does anybody write software that's not
delivered via the
the
SE all right and you're you're going
like this I want to hear about that it's
um
in fact they do uh yeah
okay seriously all right all right what
do I do
uh terminal corporate like deployment
systems okay almost as it was on the web
they're not actually facing like public
Hangouts um but do they get delivered to
a browser no do they get delivered to a
phone no do they get delivered to a
printer I do not want my star in fact
some Shooters
um okay basically just like deployment
systems yeah surveying committed dollars
and who else somebody in the back
what do you do
um
okay so so ship stop
oh anybody else all right yeah well you
know what I want yay to work on do you
work on
Chef
so so but still right
at least in a lot of the cases
um well I hope this is going to be
interesting
um for you uh if not and uh more you
then you can leave and I won't feel a
bit bad I'm still gonna talk for like a
long time by myself anyway
um uh what are what these are um there
is a
somewhat of a the way I like to to to
view software development
um from from brain cells to production
uh is through this lens it offers like a
really uh I don't know a good mental map
for me so
in any definition of continuous
delivery and if we say continuous
delivery if I say continuous deployment
um nobody but just humble is going to be
all unglued about it so so Just Go With
It Go With It um uh
what are some of the what might be what
can we say uh is a
a belief about continuous deployment
anybody
it happens often so about rates what
else it's very modern it's very modern
um so it's so it's modern and happens
often anybody else
short Cycles what's that short short
Cycles
almost again about somewhat about about
frequency as well possibly size right
uh fully automation fully automated
all right we're gonna have a blast with
that one
um for bug fixing it's good for bug
fixing
highly test it
it's highly tested this is going to be
awesome
um
let's talk about ideals
um all right all right let's let's just
let's just start right here
um
Let's uh let's let's put aside let's put
aside down I think here I think you're
right that it's modern
um
but let's uh so let's set that aside for
a second because we'll want to come back
to that a little bit later actually
that's a good sort of anchor
um for that
um so often and short
um largely what we hear is the
continuous deployment sort of Embraces
the idea of small but frequent changes
what's the idea there the idea there is
that a small but a small change is a
change that whose surface area is is uh
is is uh well small I mean the surface
area of
um of either code to be fair you could
also say you could apply to Hardware as
well
um what does this mean it means that in
diagnosis when looking at something's
wrong after something is in production
if you only deployed five lines then you
could only uh then you only will have to
look at five lines right that's kind of
the the notion set aside that that's
completely false and there's no such
thing as immutability
um but especially when it comes to the
build the pretty trivial to to uh uh to
build something that has more complexity
than this that uh or
indeterminism than five lives but let's
just say it's a good start and it's a
reasonable place to start
um okay so let's see now we'll take our
five take our five lines and we'll take
uh
what's what should we do with that let's
take testing okay
why would we test something
come back with me to sort of first
principles here why would we test these
five lines
to know if they work right exactly
what's that let's see the break of it
see if they break other things that's
that's that's a really good point
probably one that we spend not enough
time recognizing uh deliberately and
explicitly but that's almost certainly
the thing that's that's most concerning
at least to those folks who uh who who
sort of attempt this continues to blame
business
if you've ever written five lines and
the five lines have no plug at all
but may trigger a late book somewhere
else
that's that sort of speaks to the point
um so
why wouldn't we want to test we want to
see if they work what are the various
ways that we can that we can confirm
that something works
integration test
your requirements requirements to start
with
so
I think what we're talking about
and where is he there
um I think what we're talking about here
is that testing might be if we consider
that testing is a way that we gain
confidence
that
that this that this thing that we wrote
is going to do what we expect so in that
case it's about expectations get
Gathering confidence about your
expectations as it turns out doesn't
actually it doesn't have to be
prescriptive and we do this every day we
take the train the trains are never
going to run on time we fix our phones
autocorrect we course correct in ways
that give us uh
confidence in all of the actions that we
do when writing software is no uh
there's no exception the thing is that
we don't ever men we never noticed those
things because they come like
muscle memory
um and we generally notice them when
they don't work for us instead of when
they do work for us
let me ask you this this is what's the
possibility
of not testing any of those five lines
and it being okay
possible
right
two things it's impossible
um
so
why would we again does testing code
take more time than than not testing the
code
right and time is one
so if there's a decent there's a
non-zero chance that it's not going to
break anything and it's not going to
surprise us then why would we test it
it's because we believe that there's a
larger likelihood that it will break
than not right otherwise we would we
would test it now how many folks would
run an entire full battery of Suites for
an HTML content
wow this is we're changed nights we've
changed bits let me ask you this RN
minus RF
dot slash star
versus starred
right two characters
you can do a huge amount of surprise
by two characters
but if we laugh about throwing a full
battery test at an HTML comment which is
could be really long it could be a lot
of characters right it just means that
we bring our experience to the table
um and so that means that uh history
matters so there is no science here we
can talk about statistics that's a
different talk but what we are talking
about is confidence and once we say that
we can gain confidence in ways other
than testing then what we can do is then
we can lay off the part about code
coverage we can lay off
the idea that confidence can only come
from following software development
practices that were written in a book
maybe a long time ago a long time ago
when we shipped software except for the
guy in the back so where we ship
software where the cost of deploying it
was so high
that the emphasis was on testing
um
so confidence uh one of the things that
um so
tests I haven't argued against tests I
just want to investigate and sort of put
it on the operating table and pull it
apart for a little bit so that we can um
so we can investigate our own
assumptions when it comes to how much
confidence we place in a test
what might be another way to gain
confidence besides a test
experience but let's operationalize that
um
monitoring right
monitoring knowing uh and monitoring
itself is a really super rich topic
um so monitoring that's a that's a
decent one what do we mean by that
works right right so but then we're
faced with other decisions right
what to look for
right you can't just say oh we monitored
it follow this place what's that
follow the specs the
the specs that were written by the
person who hasn't seen the software yet
so we'll follow those
um certainly we should ignore them but
what else should we do oh well we could
say that we could do you have a
suggestion
yeah exactly this this is another one
you said dog fooding uh internal usage
this is something we do at Etsy quite
quite a lot
but again we could do that without
monitoring things
what I want to bring up is that while
monitoring is a very reasonable thing
you could say and I would say maybe
I think no assessment is said in this as
such in as well as that like it's kind
of like testing but after
um and uh but again it is a conference
inspiring stuff just like tests you have
to make a decision I'm going to test for
divide by zero I'm going to test for
these I'm going to test for these
conditions these all of these conditions
that I have thought of
how many times have we written a test
I had a whole lot of tests
and it just so happens that the way it
broke was in the way that that I didn't
I didn't test for
um
same thing with monitoring we could say
monitor all the things this becomes a
combinatorial problem because we could
we could look at uh what's a common lab
we could look at time series graph we
get a new piece of code we can
um graph a bunch of things we'll grab
the server time graph the application
code execution graph the memory
footprint what else we could graph
IP requests ethernet frames
uh used CPU Heap CPU user CPU system CPU
DNS requests database queries
kernel system calls which one anymore
interrupts interrupts right open Final
descriptors for a thing
um uh yeah right
lots of stuff
um
payloads
header sizes something switches contact
switches
painting swapping all of this stuff
awesome
what's the chance that we uh have an
ability to put more monitors in place
then we can pay attention to
so now just like writing a test we've
got some decisions to make and there are
downsides uh we believe that there's
upsize and it's actually reasonably it's
a reasonable suggestion to say monitor
second thing you say is all right I'm
going to monitor what should I monitor
um try to monitor the execution of
particular code blocks right we wrote
this thing probably what four years ago
called stat d
pretty awesome kind of democratized
metrics collection at Etsy and
essentially boils down to if you have if
you within your application
you get a graph for the cost of writing
one line of code and that line is that
long
you also almost certainly spend more
keystrokes if you're an emacs user
um so uh so so what does that mean it
means that as of yesterday we have 411
000 time series graphs so you could say
we want to gain a lot of disability this
is going to give us confidence this you
wouldn't be wrong about that
there's a downside the downside is that
just by having as many graphs we can
feel super confident so we got it all
covered
now
I think that we can probably write more
graphs than most people what should we
do with those graphs should we
stare at the we could make a dashboard
but what if I have to go to lunch
so we're gonna make an alert right so if
something's wrong
uh or something's weird or anomalous and
we'll have a page of human that's what
we do
okay another decision what's the
threshold
well what's the what's the relationship
between a false positive
and a false negative
how often will I get a page and say this
is probably not that big of a deal and
then put it down in which case
uh well let me ask you this how many uh
how many folks Drive
you have a car
okay keep your hand up if you have an
alarm on your car
okay put your hand up if you've heard a
car alarm in the last week
okay surprising that you even noticed
the alarm went off
um
that's a it's a weird thing right most
people don't pay attention to Car Wash
but they do just phone alarms
um so what does this tell us about
alerts it means that we want to know
when things are broken or unexpected in
the exact same way as tests
but the thing is is it requires us to
know what to look for
um and our imagination is going to be
limited because let me ask another
question how many how many of you have
an internal corporate Wiki
all right awesome
how many people have gone to a Wiki page
in your corporate Wiki where you know
immediately that you're looking at
outdated information
okay it meant it was because the person
who wrote could have been you I've
certainly written them the person who
wrote the Wiki page
filled it with information that makes
sense to them at the time
just like the person who wrote a test
just like the person who put a an alert
in just like the person who met Kuduro
graph it made sense to them at the time
probably because they were prompted it
was they they good intentions I better
write this down so somebody else could
could take a look at this I'm going to
write this test so it doesn't so I don't
know if it breaks I'm going to write
this graph so I'll know if uh or this
alert so I know it's doing what I'd
expect but the thing is is over time
continuous deployment we just heard it's
often
small and frequent
I don't know Daniel how many how many
times did Etsy deploy the web stack
today
30 something whatever as long as it's
more than three
um uh so so hold on so I'm going to
encode my not my knowledge my
assumptions and my expectations about
what the future should look like good or
bad in alerts and graphs and what you
pages and tests
which isn't to say they're almost
certainly Wiki pages that are still very
relevant maybe half of them maybe all of
them
but the fact that they can drift just
like tests just like metrics just like
alerts means that we have to continually
keep our uh imagination
uh alive right and no one person is
going to be able to keep an imagination
engaged and asking the questions and
sort of remaining sensitive to failure
or paying attention to
whether the rules is what we're already
talking about are rules and procedures
whether those assumptions are still
valid
tomorrow
or three months from now or six months
from now
um I can't even walk I don't know how to
use a calendar
on my phone forget about keeping all of
that in my head so what does that mean
that means that we end up working in
teams how many people who are how many
people here are solely meaning zero not
not titles or anything like that are the
only person in their uh company who is
responsible for writing tests
awesome
I expected at least one person to say
that and that's good I'd say that maybe
a couple years ago that we would see
some parents
um that's good because you need to have
this is the reason why we have code
review right uh many eyes bug shower do
you no but if you're accelerating the
pace of delivery you don't the overhead
of communication forces you to abandon
so
quality assurance because it takes too
long that's why you need quality
insurance integrated into the
development short this is absolutely
this is absolutely fine and and I fully
agree
um
well although I might although I might
say that the the channels of
communication
move from uh what we might think of as
sort of inter-office and intra human
communication and instead we communicate
through things like
you know check its results and code
reviews and comments and and alerts
right
um so
so what does this mean it means that if
the well-intentioned and very smart
tester monitor person
puts all of their knowledge because
their knowledge in in how the code's
supposed to work
um but then if we're accepting the part
where
uh where it's probably faulty and at
least foolish to believe that the alerts
and the tests
um written two weeks ago are going to be
this are going to be absolutely the the
same and relevance as they are today
then
what are we talking what how can we talk
about ideals then
um when we when something breaks we
could say oh well there wasn't there
wasn't a test for it but this this
happens it happens a decent amount
um
let me tell a quick story
it's a really good story but it's pretty
short
um so uh we've got this we've got the
most killer security team at Sea they're
super smart uh and uh feel super super
lucky we've got this developer younger
guy super nice but younger I think he's
still actually finishing these two group
and
um he was looking to see how he was
trying to fix a fix a bug and we need to
sort of gather some information about
how this basically worked
um and so what happened was is I mean
and it was a eight line change there
were eight lines and uh he said all
right I think this is I think this looks
good uh
and he looked he said all right here are
these tests I see these tests these
tests will catch in if it's no good so
and he asked his he even asked us the
guy sits natural and actually happens to
be his manager he says hey what do you
think about this
is manager super smart too pretty senior
has been at Etsy for a long time like oh
yeah okay so all right yeah this looks
good so
um so they went to deploy it
and there was another engineer with him
and uh we go to sort of essentially what
is staging it seems uh and
um test failed and uh and he's like oh
this is good
this is this is a test on test on
checkout test on checkouts that's
checkout's kind of important I think
pretty sure so we I don't know man this
is really weird like I didn't expect
this there's only eight lines it's a
story we should ask the experts let's
ask the answers so great or bad
intimacy they're in uh auto parts are
our excellence
um and he said what's the story and at
what they didn't know at the time was
Greg uh angelicine had this particular
set of test tools this particular test
like metaphorically on the operating
table what they had noticed this was on
a Monday they had noticed on a Friday
was a a completely unrelated piece of
code went out and it sort of tickled
this one particular test in such a way
that it was flaky nothing worse than a
flaky test right
screw fake taxes your tests so like oh
we gotta fix this so so it had been
flaky like ah ran I didn't passed it
failed it's like oh yeah
it was fun so I said all right so yeah
we're working on this test oh oh so I
failed yeah it's because it's flaky we
know it's like it's actually it's
actually fine you know and the the
younger guy says well I've got a code
review
I made sure that it was test coverage on
it I know what what graphs to look at
they were like right there in front of
them
um I'm asking the folks who are on the
testing system looks awesome
cool
check out those now
um so what should you do
well it turns out that
Not only was the test of flaking but it
also when in the areas that it wasn't
flaky it it actually hit through a
different error an error that would have
that were signal this so now what do we
have here we've got the guys who know
who totally know this testing of
right and they said it looked good and
his manager said it looked good so what
can we do we can tell a story about this
guy this sort of younger guy who wasn't
paying attention we can tell a story
about him being a little bit Reckless
because it's security and it's checkout
check out that must mean that must have
mean that the error was really bad what
a crazy what a
just he just had faulty judgment
uh
we could tell all these stories but the
fact of the matter is is that that would
have happened to anyone right
so what's this what's the story gets to
us the story gets to us is that the
context that people are in when they
both write a test write write a write an
alert are they uh or write a Wiki page
or write the code manners
It also says that history matters
Greg had a history of you know uh at
least 24 hours of at least 24 hours it
was over a weekend knowing that this
particular test was flaky
um that's what led him to make that it
made sense to him no this is probably
what we're working on
um
so
we're getting a lot we're getting
further and further away from science
and hard engineering the more we talk
right and we're talking more about the
context people are in and you're right
that there's experience in there
uh
but again it it matters
so
highly talked about this so highly
tested yeah well so on that point
chemists uh test their testing patients
right calibrating yeah do we do not have
meta tests
uh what I don't know would meditests
well let me ask you this
um
how is chemistry different than software
engineering
we could cargo culture if you want
um
because context is important
um Can chemists roll back
a reaction
Folks at Three Mile Island didn't think
so either were you gonna say something
yeah
you've talked about requirements
and ideals and everything but I think
part of the agile kind of philosophy is
that you can't really know like you said
just what your software has to do in
your domain and you build all these
tests and you try to get good coverage
but then that's not really going to be
fully covered so your best tests are the
ones you write to address failures I
mean you have to expect that some things
are going Fair yeah and that's going to
inform you about your domain and your
software and your infrastructure and
right that's a teaching so
so machine learning so failure is
is part of our learning about the system
we're building absolutely absolutely but
I would argue so so would success in
fact I would say that
and I'm not the first to say this
Murphy's Law is wrong
the fact of the matter is is that not
everything that could go wrong does
in fact if anything it almost never does
the the the
again these aren't my words either the
surprising thing is not that our code
breaks it's that our code works as often
as it does
um so
if we were to count all if we were to
find the places failures are just uh
failure adjustments
um surprises that have a different name
to them right and and the actions and
the uh and the sort of the decisions
that we make in order to write this test
we're going to put this put this uh
graph into place
um all come from the same part of our
brain right the ones that ended failure
and the ones that ended success there's
it's still the same thought process it's
still the same mechanism and that that's
certainly more about the context
highly tested continuous deployment
uh I'm gonna come around who is this
part you said earlier
um you mentioned what's another way to
gain confidence well to release the the
new stuff to the internal company right
that what does that do that that reduces
in uh that reduces the surface area of
failure right which means that if it's
going to break it at least the new stuff
will break just for my company like our
customers or that it might operate for
them is that what you're getting in
yeah I mean this is a reasonable this is
sort of a reasonable thing to do if you
say you can take it even further and say
that well I'm a developer and I could
also put it into production and just
have it turned on only for me as part of
a white list
this is another way of doing things
and it is in production which means he's
using production systems if it's in
production which is where it's supposed
to land then we don't and we and we can
do it in such a way that we feel safe in
doing so
um by having confidence in our code then
we don't have to worry but we don't have
to ask the question is it failing
because my Dev environment is always a
little bit weird
and it's a little bit different Hardware
like a version of java is different it
might mean I mean it could be like how
much did that producing that surface
area five lines do you then
um
so that's that's that's one way in that
scenario what we call when we call that
we call that staff only or admin only
here
um
uh we were talking earlier before we
started about dark code
um who hasn't heard of concept of dark
good awesome okay well just we'll I'll
say it uh
so dark code there are some there are
varying ways of uh
of describing it
historically Dart code is code whose
execution path uh you you want to
receive the results of in its natural
habitat right which is production which
is uh which is
aka the only place that your business is
going to get value from it
so
um so an example the canonical example
is a number of back-end calls that your
database started that your that your
application is gonna be you're going to
talk to a search cluster or general
database talk to a caching server or
whatever and you're just not entirely
sure like you're pretty sure let's say
you did a little bit of load testing but
you're not entirely confident that
um that the workload that's in
production is going to be any good so
what could you do you could say all
right so you know what for x amount of
at the beginning of my code I'm just
going to say pick a random number if
it's below this you know if that if that
number is below you know picking a
random number between 0 and 10 to 10 if
it's below 5 then execute this code go
get all this data from these back-end
stuff and then just like whatever don't
do anything with it
throw it away just do reads or you can
do rights or whatever
um uh and that way the user experience
isn't at all affected I mean it might
affect five percent
um they might uh it might hurt but if it
hurts it's only five percent you could
even do it for at that point 0.1
and so
that way you can gain confidence in uh
more sort of complex and or what feels
risky
feels risky
not scientifically proven not
statistically uh what feels risky as
another way of gaining confidence oh in
the database oh look actually the
database is handled it not so bad you
know what yeah but I'm still not totally
sure let's turn up to ten percent let's
turn up to looks good
fifty percent rocking
75 that looks weird all right turn that
off let's go figure out ah memory league
and your users didn't know
um
and it wasn't a scramble so dark code is
another way to gain confidence
is this a test
to a certain extent
um just like a monitor just like an
alert this kind of a test
um
in that case also if the case if the
case is that it's not about the back end
calls but it's actually about user
Behavior how are they going to handle it
well let's say we do what we do like
another who's ever here used uh
Google labs in Gmail
right by the way I highly highly
recommend the I think it's like a five
minute or no it's like a 30 second
recall so like it doesn't send you a
message for 30 seconds so you're like
I'd replied on
um you should install it
um so we have prototype
groups
this is where we say our sellers uh and
our our members hey check this out we'll
get this new feature we're not entirely
sure that it's going to look like this
uh we're not entirely sure whether it's
um like it could totally break
so but we've made it as safe as we can
so if you want to come check it out jump
in our little group here uh and let us
know like is it working is it slow is it
like what do you think
um
that means like we're getting our users
to test us test for us
yes we are and we should be psyched
about it because the people who are in
those groups are so
pumped
to be doing that
because they feel like they're in on it
so there's prototypes and then there's
just plain old percentage ramp UPS
where the amount of confidence yeah
jumping back a little bit to that um
basically meeting the expectation
getting the expectation that it might
break and potentially break and uh like
fail away on queer everyone now expects
well it did maybe not now but yeah some
time ago expected Twitter to fail
sometimes right so except
the related to that or well I mean
except for the part where
well in that case well whereas all of
Twitter's members part of one big
prototype group
um I don't know if that's actually was
the intention
um I don't think about things like
content intent of fear right or like
deliberately sure
expectations
yeah absolutely so but but I want to
point this out is is that the this is
this is a uh it is a valid
um option that's not certainly going to
work for everybody
um
you can't send a man to Mars in a
prototype group for example
um
unless they're okay with that
um but
but it is about gaining confidence right
who said
software development
can only
uh can only be done
where running
tests
before it launches to every user all at
once
should be the way to begin conference
who said that
no one says that
it's just it's not a it's not a law
the only reason why we did that for ship
software is because it was damn
expensive
if you worked at AOL to recall all of
those CDs on people's front steps that's
expensive so let's you know when you're
printing CD-ROMs or or or or or putting
together much cards that's kind of
expensive so we're gonna we're gonna do
what we believe is proportional
um uh testing in the ways that we have
confidence
um
there's an another
I don't believe it's too much of a
stretch a friend of mine Andrew Schaefer
said there's another domain that uh that
does has been doing continuous
deployment for a long time and been
doing percentage ramp UPS
the pharmaceutical industry
small and frequent means clinical trials
okay so we're not really inventing
anything
but what we are doing is making a
statement about how what our values are
surrounding risk if we believe that the
risk is too large then we're going to
have an appropriate amount of uh what we
believe to be an appropriate amount of
stuff that we do to to gain confidence
and to uh
confidence
what's that
totally I mean absolutely it's kind of
like
like it's an aging test
you're totally right you're totally
right but
what I'm saying is that that well in
that case
they made use of prototype groups
in that case so what a drug doesn't but
a drug doesn't go a drug doesn't get
ingested by a human for the first time
at least in most of the countries I'm
aware of
on the same day for everyone
right that's that's the point what I'm
saying and that that's what I'm saying
is that there is an appropriate amount
what what uh
what preparation
we we go to
doesn't just
um say something about how we view risk
it also says how we uh how much
confidence we we have in our ability to
um to undeploy
our ability to respond if there is an
issue
um
so again like there's there's nothing
it isn't I what I think continuous
deployment really is is about our
ability to to to to to to call into
question
um
how
what are other ways besides
test the out of it before you do
anything
to gain confidence
um
do you think that confidence building as
a perception is a different process for
people who have the luxury of building a
new product from scratch versus trying
to fix something that's been broken
that's a good question
devoted word confidence yeah if it's the
same thing yeah no so I'll repeat the
question the question is
um
if if given two scenarios
uh somebody who's building something
brand new from scratch and versus
somebody who's been you know attempting
to fix something that's that has had
history there
um that I think the answer is is yes
because history does matter
um
they you know we've used this you know
in in operations we say that the
um the architectures of Tomorrow are
informed by the incredibly traumatic
outages of yesterday right how many
times how many times you want to say
um when you when you go to a new company
and they say oh yeah we write we write
our code in whatever mention any
language we were recording everything
and then you remember back to when you
worked at that other company that also
wrote in that language and it sucked you
hated it and you're like oh
stand Pearl no it's no good but you
don't have any like you you're
you had a terrible time but there's
extremely successful sites that run
Pearl right now
if I'm not mistaken there's a decent
there's study I would say decent but
there's a non-zero amount of Amazon that
runs Pearl
um so what does that mean it means that
we do we do bring our experience we
bring our perceptions and that's what
informs the decision we make if we
pretend that what we're doing is science
we're so full of we're not
doing science we make decisions based on
our feelings more often than we do
statistical significance
the second that we that we understand
that then it becomes a lot clearer in
the various ways we get confidence can
no no alerts no testing no security
calls this defense and depth right the
security of world talks about
vulnerabilities and and and and attack
vectors and they don't believe that
there is a single way that you become
secure
and in the same way
there's no reason why we should ensure
why we should place all of our beds on
software being safe and functional and
functional and performant
um in one particular basket
so
fully automated
uh who's that fully obviously
awesome
uh
what if you're not fully automated
mostly automated mostly automated except
for the places
where we can't figure out how to
automate it
and or it happens so
infrequent that it wouldn't be
economical to do it
or there's too much risk in automating
it right why would there be talked to
more about that why would there be risk
in automating it
I mean because look you got rid of the
human
right like you don't have the human
there so I mean what I what I when I see
fully automated I see let's get rid of
the dirty dumb human who does her fat
fingers that stuff
but why would there be a lot of risk in
fully automated something
I'm sure that you guys have processes
we certainly do yeah
I don't know
yeah absolutely probably more than you
would think and we like it like that
some people say that
because what Brett Fitz wrote a handful
of years ago is that um uh imbue is that
every that continuous deployment means
that every commit as soon as you commit
it goes to production automatically
training right
um
is that
um uh
I'm not gonna let you go tell me more
about why would it be risky to automate
something
like database vibrations for example
yeah yeah and you're changing like a lot
of stuff in the database when like five
people sitting around watching that and
yeah one person yeah
expensive right I bet you Amazon
wouldn't do that
they got Drums
um one rest with uh fully automated
something is that you know when you
write your test leads you're testing
specific things but of course you know
like you were saying earlier there
always is something that you didn't
think of so let's say some of your tests
generate graphs
um and you know according to the test
everything is cool but if a human looks
at it it seems some graph doing some
weird thing that there's not a test for
and then that's why exactly the
basically trades um
Halo coverage for for individuals so you
get narrower more accurate that's or
more consistent testing right that's a
really that's a really good way of
saying it consistent it's going to do
what it's told you got Tire Company so
it's going to lose control which means
that there's less variability you said
I'm going to test this for divide by
zero and that's what it's going to do
it's not likely sometime next week it's
going to say you know what I'm just
gonna
start testing it for
uppercase letters right
um
repeatability
but
was that when the chick hits the fan
well the is the fan right one case
that it gets talked about is available
over database failover application
before you get paid you have automated
failover they make sure that they don't
have automated fail back yeah yeah we
don't do any of that
um
through that uh
I don't I don't I don't know whether
it's not I don't know actually whether I
would feel economical to solve that
problem
um
so yes
so automation is I'm not I'm not I'm not
arguing against automation but expecting
that there comes with it inherent risks
um much some of the stuff that we talked
about before
um is still there also when you automate
something uh you can it's pretty easy to
actually to write stuff that does a lot
of things very fast right so fast that
our ability to monitor them as humans
can get like we're pretty damn slow
we're really good at making things go
fast and um
what was the quote is that uh
that
you could certainly with automation you
can make the cycle down even faster
and also not be entirely clear why
right because automation can be very
opaque especially if you have automation
that interacts with other automation
we hear a lot about this in
configuration and management
uh sorts of uh
crowds you'll hear about you know uh
uh self-healing systems or
self-repairing stuff event handlers that
will kick off a number of
rules engines if you know because then
that then then and that sort of thing
um yeah I view called a cluster immunity
right
um which sounds great at all
um
until the hits the fan in which
case that's the one time when you do
need to be able to catch up you do need
to be able to understand what's going on
but remember you automated yourself out
of the loop
so there's a there's a trade-off to me
um there is um something where if you
haven't
suggest a uh
white paper
um I am
now in the habit of doing this almost
every day
um I'm not just the dismay of all the
co-workers uh
1978 uh 1984 a woman named lisanne
Bainbridge from Cambridge wrote a wrote
a wrote a paper called the ironies of
automation
and uh
um later on a couple of other smart
folks uh sort of expanded on her a bit
and part of the irony of automation
surrounded this idea of the leftover
principle was the approach that people
make
um again like in the name of
repeatability in the name of certainty
or at least the hope of certainty that
um
uh you have this yeah you have this
leftover principle which is to say I'll
take all of the um take all of the the
easy things and then I'll automate them
um that'll make things easier for the
human
there's a problem
and usually we have to say well well if
I automate things then it'll free me up
to do more interesting things
and if we dig a Little Deeper of what
we're saying is add this to what we were
talking about earlier which I think will
agree on is that we automate all of the
things that we know how to automate
we don't automate the things that we
can't imagine
how to automate
which means actually we're not making
things
better easier for the human
we're actually giving them the hard
things to do
and leaving the computer to do the easy
things
in which case
opaqueness
figuring things out
um is is now in the hands of uh of so
there's a there's a paradox here there's
now in the hands of the you know the
human the unreliable
irrational
non-repeatable being we just gave him
all of the hard stuff
so that's what the irony of automation
is
um uh and it's a great paper it's like I
said it's I think it's from the 80s it's
I I mean it's either in 1978 or 1984. so
they're certainly dated I think they're
she she mentions
um
Catherine Ray tubes but it's a very uh
while it is dated it's super super
um
you know
um all right
so what else how long do I how old am I
supposed to talk for I'm not kidding I
would just continue to go how long did
we say what I was going to talk for
okay all right is the uh is the leftover
principle less of a concern like when a
practitioner is writing tools for
themselves or for a very small team yeah
that's a that's a really good question
and
the the world that Bainbridge lived in
uh was not one that we live in today and
that's a stark difference
a lot of the automation that we are off
in this room familiar with we are also
the users of this automation right not
that
um well for the most part
um or we or we sit or work very closely
with the people who who do use the
automation
um and in the case of Open Source
software it makes it a little bit easier
to reason about because you can can look
at it
um
so does the leftover principle I think
almost certainly if you were to ask
somebody about why changes automation
they would probably repeat what is
almost certain leftover principle
um
without it not being an entirely clear
about the Paradox inherent within the
the second is more follow along
uh of the leftover principle is
um
because what's known in human factors is
the fits list named after Paul Fitz came
from mediation
um or other or there's or some folks
call it the Maba Maba
which is
um the entirely dated
gendered men are better at machines are
better at list and this also is a
falsehood which is to say in this case
it's humans in order to bring it up to
be like truly modern humans are better
at these lists of things they're better
at induction
making decisions and taking actions
based on
missing or faulty information they are
incredibly good at uh
visual perception right
what are other things
just making judgments
computers are good at deduction right
road to calculation
um they're good at group repeatability
and so so forth so forth we have these
two lists I was like oh this is what
I'll do I'll just make sure that I'll
just do all every time I come across
these things under the shade anytime I
ever have to do these things I'll just I
won't automate that stuff
and that's fine at all except the part
is
nope
there's no uh very few activities in
Modern Life only fit within those
buckets either the computer does
something and then the human has to do
something with it and then back and
forth it is Co-op it is a Cooperative it
is a relationship not you do everything
and you do it
if you were in that world then what you
could say was that was a very
anti-devops
very siled scenario
um
so yeah but I mean I think that when we
reach for automation because that's the
that's our that's our Hammer right at
least as software Engineers if any
domain that is our Hammer that's the
thing that we do the solution is we
write code
um
uh just note that all pieces of code
um is automation
to some extent I do believe that it
actually matters if air traffic
controllers were also the ones who wrote
the software that they use
um the world may look different I don't
know exactly what that would look like
but I'm willing to that they would
probably look different or if the pilots
wrote the software for autopilot right
any other questions around this rambling
Mad Men that I am
sorry I think that the automation of the
probability of her and cost aware also
on fire
or maybe not probability that the cost
of error is just just fired you have
complexity because of complexity
so much
um uh I don't know
what is it well I believe uh manual or
simple software that this is
developments are easier to write while
some prayer them requires a lot of
abstraction and a lot of kind of
thinking from all the perspectives it's
hardly correct and automation is
definitely in that field we're really
taking a lot into account really right
and so on so one mistake you can
actually
cause the one
okay the rely on that to replace even
actually is quite dangerous so that's
what I mean I don't know
making sure that it actually works
possibly
um
I think that I think again I think that
it points to there's a there's a
language sitting around that
that can bite us here
um
at Etsy we have
we got a lot of tests how many tests do
we have a lot for a little a lot
a lot
fifteen or twenty thousand
um
it was outdated as of as soon as it came
out of his mouth
we now probably have 15 000 in one pen
two and three um uh and Etsy we deploy
production
manually
we've got a big the button is green it
says Deploy on it and it's on a web page
and anyway we want to deploy to
production you press it
could we say that's manual
I don't know the human triggers it
the human doesn't
package up all the bites on floppies and
try it out Center
um
is our sync automation
look it's a computer
so it's all automated
some things are triggered
you could say something contributed by
the humans some things are not triggered
by humans but what happens in between
uh is where the complexity lies a lot
the complexity doesn't just fit in the
in the code we don't get to like wash
our hands and say like uh it's complex
because the code no it's about our
relationship with the code right we just
talked about a number there's nothing I
didn't talk about anything that's
technical here I didn't write one bit of
code
on this on this on these white boards
because there's nothing technical about
confidence and in how we choose them
um
so
does it cost more I I don't know if it
did
would that what what can we do with that
information
um I would say that in every every
decision that we make uh or
action we take
um
in uh in the game and getting like this
software to do this thing so that the
business can do the work
um and make money or the world a better
place or whatever it's supposed to do or
kill people whatever it's supposed to do
um uh
then at every at every place we've got
these this tension between
being efficient and being thorough
and it would believe that the cost is
going to be really high we may Arrow the
side on being thorough we think that the
cost of getting to Market is going to be
more than the cost of failure in once we
get there and be more efficient
it's not that there's like a one true
way of getting up and getting at that is
I would say is 15 000 tests enough
would is 14 000 enough
is 16 000 enough
I don't know I don't know what the
formula is I don't think you'll be half
one time so I think that I think the
answer a long answer is that it's
context sensitive the actionable thing
that we can do is to call out when we
are
uh when we're explicit about being
thorough or efficient right we see this
all the time this is this is what's
known as technical debt come across a
piece of code there's a comment in the
code if it says something like
must remember to take this out later
right so what can we ask when we come
upon that
who has written that comment before
right I would say it probably suck as an
engineer if you haven't
um uh just kidding
no you're terrible because
um because and then it exp you're at
least a little bit more explicit in that
I have chosen to do this in a way that
is different than I could also Imagine
It
we then get to ask questions about that
why do we usually do it because we
probably committed to a launch date or
we committed to doing something else
that prevented us from doing it the
right way the first time
how often would we find bugs in that
code preceded by that versus code that's
not perceived by that comment
I don't know but there is something
worth if there is something worth
calling out that we were explicit like
I have an awareness that we could we
could do this differently
but the cost of doing so whether they
whether it's a financial cost or a
cognitive cost or a time estimate cost
or anything like that
um it's not high enough to write it
good question I did have a question
um just stepping back a little bit let's
say you wanted to move towards a model
of continuous deployment let's say
hypothetically speaking you are on
semi-scheduled releases and it was a
very painful and inefficient process
hypothetically
hypothetically speaking
and by the way they are um they are all
built in Pearl so
let's say you wanted to move towards a
model of continuous deployment so what
would be because I had thought that you
know what we were missing was the lack
of full fully automated
but what I'm hearing is that that's not
the case
they were to have that in place that
like what's the low-paying foods that
you need to have in place if you want to
move towards that and then part two is
how do you know if it's the right model
for you
know that's a really long question
um but it's a really good question
so
so that leads me to more questions for
you but before I get there I would say
to uh what would be the problem that
you're looking to solve is the problem
that you want to solve the fact that
deployments are painful
continuous deployment does not
have to be the only way they can do that
I would ask about why it's beautiful
if you believe it's technically painful
then there are ways that you could
rate you could you could ask more
questions about why technically it's
almost certainly as part of that
conversation that you might have with
co-workers
um what's going to show up are non-hard
uh
non-hard science backed by statistics
bits that we talked about before you're
going to come up with
philosophical approaches philosophical
thoughts on how dip software should be
deployed and given your
current you know scenario so
I can tell you how it works here at Etsy
I will tell you that a lot of the stuff
that we're talking about is only
there's no there's no single
there's no single one thing
um
there are a number of things that
companies who are successful that
continuous deployment do that are common
through them
um but I don't think there's any one you
can't just say ah no matter what you do
you got to do this
you could actually have a terrible
deployment process you can it can be
manual
um but you can be continuous deployment
and and your deployment could be super
painless
when I first got it Etsy
the testing infrastructure was up in
Amazon web services it ran like clusters
and build Bots and it started it just
creeped under the weight of what a you
know uh
we just simply asked too much for it for
from it for too long
so we did what we knew we should have
done and we nuked every test so this is
before uh Greg and his his uh cracked
Navy SEAL Team came but for a decent
amount of time we just simply didn't
have any tests there were no tests
um uh at when I worked at Flickr before
Etsy we I I don't even think we had we
didn't have any tests
zero and we deployed ten times a day
um
I mean zero tests there was no Hudson
there was towards the end we we had some
tests
but we did not have we didn't have we
didn't have what we have here at Etsy
you have manual people clicking around a
lot
of hip Developers
right product people
we had all of these
we had the dark Hood we had staff we had
ramp UPS
um so again like I could say you could
have the most killer rocket automated
testing you could have the most expert
people who've been in the in the domain
about how to write tests and how to
write them efficiently and how to make a
testing infrastructure run so there's
tests run super fast and go cover to
blah blah and still suck at it
um
I can so I don't want to give you like a
like a really like crap answer which is
it depends
um even though that's actually what I'm
giving you um uh I can tell you a couple
of things that I feel are
reasonably worth looking into
and that is
making and that is bringing Developers
touching production
as often as possible
and making and and having and making
sure that the people who are right
people who write the code
are responsible for it in production
once it's there
um uh my my friend Mike Nygaard who
wrote this awesome book called release
it if you haven't read it you're totally
missing out it's one of the best books
um he it's essentially about operations
I don't even know if he can do it at the
time but he was writing about operations
from a software developer background and
he said something super smart which is
that
writing software and preparing for only
the the like calling the release of the
the code into production
um it for a developer that's like
preparing for the birth of a baby and
paying no attention to the idea that
you're going to raise it
and it's hard to argue with so getting
developers as close to production here
at Etsy it is that you wrote the code
look you're you're seeing drill Smart in
the interview why don't you have the
stones to deploy it yourself
so then when you do that
you don't get crazy Cowboys
deploy The Boy The Boy I Don't Care
divided by zero like you don't get that
what you get is people rising to the
occasion to look for places maybe places
that that
uh that operations people in QA and
designers and many other people out
people who even software other software
Developers they know what it makes for
their code they they know what their
what they want their code to do they
they are the author they are the expert
in their ability so they ought to be the
way they ought to be the ones to be able
to dictate what of the ways that they
can feel confident in it
so that's what I would say there's a
couple of ways of doing this I've heard
some companies having like let's just
get one team
uh to one developer team to start this
idea
um
we should rename the team too
do like a devops team or something like
that
I I don't subscribe to that notion
um where you get square receiving Daniel
said how long will it take how long will
it be before I say the word devops in
this in the stock it's just a word we'd
ever say let's see it's like like it
feels weird to say it it's like it feels
weird to like like peeing on the floor
in a conference room like that's how
weird it feels to say well we're going
to devops this right like you know or
something on those lines I personally
will do what we did here which is gold
turkey all the Developers
deploy
and when you do that
you know here there are a number of
speaking of monitoring there are a
number of teams here at Etsy software
development teams who they they now have
their own on-call alerting schedules
they are writing there are there are
alerts nagios alerts that are written by
developers that operations haven't even
seen
they don't even page operations
um because there is and there is an
ownership I I am I'm responsible for
this code if it's awesome
I want to be you know I I'm I'm by
deploying this I'm signing my name to
the code
and in a not so and that kind of goes
well around
it because you know that's kind of our
business is to sort of Empower what
people feel passionate about making to
sell to other people right we've got you
know these These are uh handmade sort of
rolling rolling tables over here sellers
stamp their name
because there's their site my name is
John Smith I made this mahogany table
it's awesome
um you know uh my name is Ray corbeck I
wrote this code if it could if it if it
explodes I come at me because I want to
know why
it broke so I can figure out what to do
the next time
what's up
we make them Deploy on their first day
ah
you mean like you're getting it like
code ownership well I mean you're
talking about you know I I wrote this
yeah yeah
now I'm gone now who owns it well are
you in like gone as in a different team
or not at the company anymore I
so in the case that you're in this does
happen right
um if you're still if you're interested
in a different team and that feature is
um is is is is still like providing
value to the business then you probably
told little walk somebody else through
that code regardless it's still in the
same repo anybody can read and change it
anyway there's no defined lines between
don't there's no don't touch my
um so uh
but once so once you get like
once you get it so that people can
whatever do the GitHub thing and submit
pull requests but I want to help you out
here
um then that's okay it's messy
uh which makes it awesome
one more question
I didn't answer your question very well
okay I only want 30 or more seconds and
and then take one more question
um
developers deploy
operations
gets to a place where they're psyched
about it
um where they're psyched about
developers deploying
um somebody people have asked me in the
past I'm like so operations at Etsy
doesn't handle releases and then say no
and and people have said then what do
they do
and I was like you know what
what an Ops organization doesn't have
releases as part of their
responsibilities
you would be amazed how much proactive
work
gets believe me they are the busiest
they are some of the busiest uh you know
Innovative groups that I've certainly
never been a certain part of
um and
yeah I guess that those those two things
is probably a good start other people
say one by deploy
you'd probably be a
negotiate if you did that as well
it's by having a button on a web page
that says deploy
then it deploys or we had a we had a
Cuba to production
yeah it's we had a script listening it's
in your chat then you you bought it yeah
it runs the script and boom with your
website there you go that so you want to
have one a bit like let's say there's a
number of steps
write a bunch of verbose logs but to
make it so that you've got one trigger
that makes the thing go
um okay last question
um
University's
contact information
but how do you
have uh
optimism bias and all that especially
among development scientists everybody
does this kind of work sure how do you
develop confidence in your risk
assessment
how do you develop confidence in your
risk assessment
so on first let me take a quick stab at
the the supporting premise you're right
there is a lot of research optimism bias
is not even close to being the only
cognitive bias that we fall prey to
right
um and so
um
and they absolutely influence how we
view how we view this
um and how we oversimplify
and reduce the
um the actions especially when we're
trying to describe the past
um reduce our uh the
you know the what went into a particular
decision or a particular action whether
it made sense or not
um
wait what was the second part of your
question
oh yeah
right right right right so essentially
what you're asking is
um
how do you make sure that you're not you
you're accurately figuring out the
I mean the argue this because it's risky
and you're not doing things that yeah
you shouldn't be doing this right right
so there's a couple of thoughts there
and and a lot of it essentially comes
down to learning how to learn
and we didn't talk about learning but
essentially what it gets at it gets that
experience it gets it path dependency it
gets that history matters
um
uh
what
so if risk is informed by our history
and our imagination then
um
and and if we believe that the limits
that we've set for ourselves of risky
versus not risky
change over time
meaning if we feel as though we're going
to be more successful
if we have a more hit a larger hit a
longer history of success right then
there is there is a danger that we are
um
that we are becoming wait for it
complacent
this is what you were getting at
yeah how do we have confidence that our
risk assessments are up to date
essentially
um we can't
remaining sensitive to the possibility
of failure
even in the in the in the wake of a huge
amount of success is a total
is a thing and it doesn't have to it
doesn't require the internet to
sort of thing
to uh to underscore this is anybody know
a good example you talked about at the
devops conference with the philosophy
conference day of Richard Cooks yeah
description of when you become
complacent you move closer to the
boundary of failure right
it's an excellent talk what's up
sort of almost Black Swan Theory
uh
but not certainly unrelated when Black
Swan gets it at the idea of uh the idea
of fundamental surprises uh
what Richard cook spoke about it in that
philosophy if you haven't seen it was
normalization of deviants
the sample here is that how confident
should we be about launching this
shuttle when it's a little bit colder
out it hasn't been this cold but we've
got Confidence from a number of other
also we've done this 23 times
um
in that same talk Richard said that uh
that that most thoughts on safety
including software safety can be traced
back to we owe it all to Three Mile
Island I would say this normalization of
deviance this came from
um the the Challenger later the Colombia
disaster and it's still I think very
very uh
uh appropriate we still have there's a
there's yet another paper see you've got
me now twice doing it um by uh two guys
named Starbuck and Milliken and they
said they have three you you could break
down three probabilities of future
success and failures uh three theories
and the first one is
your path your your history doesn't
matter and there's no way that you can
predict whether you're going to be
successful or or or uh
have a failure
the second one is the
a history of success may make you more
uh feel more confident about having a
subsequent success and less confident
about having a subsequent failure right
yeah the the third one is the flip right
which is uh if you've been successful
the longer you've been successful you're
waiting for the other shoe to drop the
longer you've been successful the more
likely you are going to have as a as a
failure the next time
um
the
the notion that that normalization and
deviance is is to one except that you're
not going to know where the boundary is
until you hit it
um
and
two that it's uh if you if you leave out
the conversation or dialogue about how
you normalize uh your your work Richard
did a awesome good awesome job
about um telling a story if you've ever
had a toddler and then he tells the
story of like okay so you're in the
kitchen you're cooking on the stove or
whatever and the toddler comes in you
know it's hot stove and there's grease
and whatever and the dollar says okay
listen don't come in the kitchen I'm I'm
like a cooking here
I don't want you to get burned okay
right it says don't don't cross this
threshold right stay in the living room
don't come in the kitchen linoleum
starts here and what is the first thing
that toddler does is go straight up to
the line right and then uh and then if
and then if you turn it back okay
and then go back
and then you turn around and they're
going to come forward and you might jump
over the line nothing happened you might
go back right and then they'll come
forward and the next thing you know
they're standing right next to you this
is normalization of deviance so
40 times a day
which 75 be okay
we're about 150.
would this work with 500 developers
instead of 115
.
um
I I don't know I think that one thing
that is worthwhile uh is to continually
ask the question whether or not we we
are what whether we think we are up
against about career and just note that
this normalization the normalization of
deviances is like this like it's a thing
it's not unrelated to what's known as
risk homeostasis this idea that with
every Improvement we make to any system
no matter what no matter what kind of
system it is
um we're going to erode a boundary like
we're not going to be uh
um say we got a system and we let's just
take regular capacity planning right we
replace we take advantage of Moore's Law
and replace a bunch of servers with a
bunch of faster ones now are we gonna
I'll just reap the benefit of having
that or we will we run them hotter
does ABS anti-lock brakes cause people
to go slower
or to stay the same or do they go faster
they go faster
um so you know I don't know the answer
to the question uh I mean I I think I
think probably
the only way that I like to think about
it
um especially here at Etsy is to keep
the diet keep the dialogue alive in
whenever we're making decisions
sorry I'm getting kicked out
thanks for uh for humoring me